[російською] Це не той апарат,
яким ви зможете полетіти у магазин по хліб.
[російською] Він з десятиметровими крилами.
Це грубо кажучи.
[російською] Він не для цієї цілі стоїть.
[російською] Ви єднаєтеся із живою природою,
слухаєте вітер у вухах.
[російською] Ви летите над селом,
дивитесь, як качки крякають над озером, низько.
[російською] Ви незалежні від висоти,
вам не потрібно шукати потоки.
[російською] Можете тиху погоду обрати зранку
і летіти без шуму — 30, 50 метрів, 100 метрів.
[російською] Висота пташиного польоту найкрасивіша.
[російською] Туманами милуватися, ріками, поворотами і т.д.
[російською] Чого не може інший апарат.
[російською] Я, взагалі, з дитинства не любив бензин.
[російською] Коли мені розповідали про двигуни,
ті мене не захоплювали.
[російською] Тому що було розуміння: якщо ти в пустелю
заїхав на дорогій машині і закінчився бензин,
[російською] то ти можеш стояти над тією машиною,
гладити її, цілувати, спати в ній, але це просто шмат заліза.
[російською] А махоліт дає змогу літати
без бензину на сотні кілометрів.
[російською] Довго розбирався, коли в обласній бібліотеці
у Франківську сидів і переглядав різні двигуни і науки.
[російською] І шукав якусь енергію.
[російською] Мені довелося все знаходити і вивчати самому.
[російською] Тоді інтернету не було і взагалі про махольоти
були тільки «Крила Батьківщини» чи «Техніка молоді».
[російською] Коли я дізнався про резонанс,
почав вникати через журнали, книги.
[російською] Коли вже зупинився на ньому, затвердився,
тоді просто почав спостерігати.
[російською] Резонанс застосовується широко,
хоча люди навіть не помічають його.
[російською] Це чиста енергія, вона опирається на повітря.
[російською] Якщо ви стрибаєте на батуті,
то от як у вас використовується енергія:
[російською] ви коли стали на батут,
можете від землі себе підкинути, підстрибнути.
[російською] Якщо я важу 70 кілограмів, я легко стрибаю.
[російською] Тепер я підстрибну
і в мене ще 70 кілограмів додається — постріл.
[російською] Тобто я вище стрибаю.
Коли вперше підстрибую, я високо не можу стрибнути.
[російською] А коли падаю, то накопичую енергію
і тисну вже не 70 кілограмів, наприклад, а 120 і більше.
[російською] Я відтягую пружину сильніше,
і вона мене вище підкидає з другого разу.
[російською] Я використовую своє тіло і силу тяжіння,
[російською] а пружини відіграють роль акумулятора —
те саме у махольоті.
[російською] Пружини відіграють роль акумулятора:
накопичують і віддають,
[російською] накопичують вагу апарата і тіла людини.
[російською] Вже 32-й рік пішов.
[російською] Це коли я вже почав стабільно займатися махольотом.
[російською] Не раз ночами не спав — було так,
що ціле літо тільки бігав у магазин, їв і знову робив.
[російською] І день, і ніч.
Я сотні крил зробив, із закрутками...
[російською] Розробляв крила, бувало,
в день по 70 крил робив.
[російською] Я ще не полетів, я тільки спланував з гори,
коли в мене ще коліс не було, з пружинами вже.
[російською] Я пролетів за шість секунд 70 метрів.
[російською] Вже 32-й рік пішов...
[російською] Це коли я вже почав стабільно займатися махольотом.
[російською] Довго, бо це «міцний горішок».
[російською] Люди в космос вже полетіли,
а досі ніхто не полетів махаючи крильми.
[російською] Хіба це не цікаво — літати без бензину?
[російською] Хай навіть цю ідею беруть,
переробляють, мені яка різниця, аби лиш люди швидше літали.
[російською] Я, по ідеї, давно мав би закінчити,
якби фінанси не гальмували.
[російською] Бо як тільки є якісь гроші,
я від всього відмовляюсь і роблю махоліт,
[російською] а нема фінансів — мусиш шукати,
а то все тягнеться, як резина.
[російською] Зараз остання стадія — випробування.
[російською] Мені й малювати хочеться —
дуже навіть хочеться,
[російською] просто я розділяю: поки тепло —
працюю тут, хочу працювати фізично.
[російською] Я взимку малюю.
[російською] І отак розділяю — по пів року.
[російською] Бо і то, і то люблю.
[російською] Ось моє село і рідний дім.
[російською] У мене тут просто —
це не кімната, де я живу, а майстерня.
[російською] Я тут узимку малюю.
[російською] Я із садочка малюю,
мене з двох років віддали у дошкільний дитбудинок,
[російською] а потім вже був дитбудинок, коли в школу пішов.
[російською] В іншу відправили, в Білорусії.
[російською] Що уявляю, те й малюю.
[російською] У мене розкуповують картини,
я й за кордон їздив малювати.
[російською] Я люблю з голови малювати,
змальовувати мені нудно.
[російською] У мене всередині фантазія і весь час
[російською] у мене проблеми між малюванням і винаходами.
[російською] Я такі картини малюю — вигляд зверху,
[російською] замки, долини малюю, каньйони,
водоспади і т.д. — я люблю фантазувати.
[російською] У мене не раз, коли лежу, мозок розпалюється
і я просто літаю в живій картині.
[російською] Політ, краса зверху, вигляд зверху...
[російською] Романтика...
[російською] Це мрія людини — літати.
[російською] Річ у тому, що в повітрі — простір,
у будь-якому місці можете повернути праворуч чи ліворуч.
[російською] А на землі ви не можете в будь-якому місці
повернути, вас дорога веде і не дає [повернути].
[російською] То будинок не дає, то рівчак,
то стовпи не дають.
[російською] Ви обмежені. А в повітрі цього немає —
повертай у будь-якому місці.
[російською] І вам хочеться співати, радіти і т.д.
[російською] Я хочу літати, якщо встигну.
А не встигну, то не встигну. Ну що поробиш.